a little bit of breaking news to bring  you now a departure date has been  announced for the most senior police  officer in the country you'll remember  dame cressida dick announced that she  was resigning her post as the  metropolitan police commissioner after  she said she no longer enjoyed the  confidence of the london mayor sadiq  khan her last day will be sunday april  the 10th and the deputy commissioner  steve house will serve as acting  commissioner while the recruitment  process is ongoing to find dame  cressida's successor  a spokesperson for the mayor has said  the mayor thanks dame cressida dick for  her decades of public service and he has  been clear that candidates for the next  commissioner must have a plan to restore  the trust and confidence of londoners so  april the 10th will be dane cressida  dick's last day in post